щодо цього законопроекту вже ламали
списані один раз і багато було різних
дискусій в принципі в ньому залишилося
достатньо протирічіві норми і я вважаю
що тут дійсно до другого читання є що
зробити У нас є час для того щоб
захищати персональні дані але я не
розумію чому у нас немає часу для того
щоб захищати наших героїв яких сьогодні
Російська Федерація тримає у своїх
тюрмах в оленівці та в інших місцях на
тимчасово окупованій території коли
зараз збираються в розбомбленому
рашистами Маріуполі влаштувати на сцені
театра судилище
знаєте в мене болить серце від цього І я
просто дійсно не розумію я дякую 120 е-е
представникам воно більшості які
проголосували щойно за включення до
порядок денного звернення Верховної Ради
з приводу подій оленівці Я не розумію
інших які цього не підтримали Я вам
просто прочитаю що ви не підтримали
зокрема заклик до Організації Об'єднаних
Націй і Червоного Хреста і навіть і
лікарів без кордонів зробити все можливе
для того щоб витягти із полону медиків
жінок в першу чергу для того щоб вжити
всіх максимальних заходів для того щоб
зробити життя наших по
військовополонених кращими Але
найголовніше Ви не хочете підтримати
визнання Російської Федерації закликом
визнати російську федерацію державою
терористам заклик заклик до відключення
свіфту від останніх банків як засіб
тиску теж якщо Російська Федерація не
хоче віддавати українських полонених Я
цього не розумію але Живіть з цим